[Music]
humans are going back to the Moon right
now the Moon is the target of more
missions than at any time since the
Apollo era the US and China have
ambitious projects to build permanent
bases on the lunar surface and where
they go business is following they all
want to share in the promised new lunar
economy you'll see tourism you'll see
commercialization I would say of data on
the moon there will be an entertainment
element of it over the next 10 years 400
missions we forecast $137 billion
cumulative Market to get there first
we'll need the infrastructure to support
a lunar economy someone will have to
build the landing pads the power
stations and Communications networks
needed for these permanent bases then
the question will be whether there
really is money to be made from
exploiting Earth's cold Barren satellite
Beyond relying on government
[Music]
contracts so what exactly are the space
agencies trying to do that has excited
talk of a lunar economy ditch ideas of
lunar cities instead think of the
International Space Station where a
handful of astronauts spend months at a
time learning to live and work in space
or of the Polar research stations where
scientists from around the world go to
study in some of the toughest conditions
on the planet we'll have research
outposts they're going to be operated
much like we might operate an outpost in
the outback or say on an offshore
platform so I think we'll have
rotational Crews so the facility itself
would be permanently occupied but the
people would rotate in and out Jim free
is the man leading the US effort to
return humans to the Moon NASA sees it
as a training ground for living and
working on Mars now we can put systems
close to home to 100 plus thousand miles
away from home but closer than Mars and
see how they operate in roughly the same
gravitational environment we've had
humans on the moon before but not for
long duration so what ises that partial
gravity mean to the human system to our
other systems so that we learn it now
close to home relative to Mars we can
also simulate a Mars mission with the
moon so we're going to have a lunar
orbiting station around the Moon called
Gateway and we can send our crews and
they can live on Gateway for six months
like their transiting out to Mars for 6
months then we can send them down to the
lunar surface for 30 days like we plan
to do at Mars and have them have to
adjust from the zero gravity micro
gravity environment to a partial gravity
and then bring them back to Gateway for
six months and then bring them home so
the Moon from our perspective touches
Mars in every way except Landing through
an
atmosphere the first Port of coal in
this new lunar Rush is going to be the
moon's South Pole both the US us and
China are targeting the region and
sometimes even the same Landing sites
but why the South
Pole that's where you're going to find
Institute resource utilization missions
trying to find water trying to find
oxygen uh trying to find hyrogen trying
to find other minerals and material that
will be able to make um air for
astronauts to breathe estimates vary
greatly on how much there might be it
could be as high as 6 billion tons and
so if we can first prove that it's there
and then access it that water could
provide our astronauts with air and
water but then when we split that water
into hydrogen and oxygen makes a
fantastic inspace propellent NASA is
turning to the private sector to help
cut the costs of its missions instead of
Contracting to build a rocket it wants
to buy the ride from companies such as
SpaceX and blue origin and this is one
of the fundamental differences to the
Apollo era it means that others can use
those Services too takes advantage of
the capital that's out there gets things
done for us as a service where we're not
owning all the infrastructure but then
allows these other missions to happen as
well for private Industries much like in
low worth orbit we pay for crew to go to
the space station those same
capabilities are now taking people on
private Astron missions to the space
station or even independent missions
as SpaceX did a couple years ago of
launching people to low earth orbit on
their own building the foundations of Al
luner economy for returning to the moon
are are really rooted in what NASA's
always done the Partnerships that we've
developed for this lunar economy start
really in our uncrewed missions the
commercial lunar payload Services was
designed to get our payloads on the moon
and encourage people to build Landers to
land our payloads but then also also
allow them to carry other payloads from
various organizations that they raise as
part of their capital and it allows us
to get the data we need back to do our
science which is fundamental to what
we're doing on the lunar surface and
also to understand the lunar environment
Elon Musk SpaceX supported by billions
of dollars in NASA contracts has
revolutionized the cost of accessing
space with its reusable Falcon 9 rocket
its success has spawned a host of cap
startups with over 100 companies around
the world aiming to carry satellites
into low earth orbit now musk's gigantic
Starship promises to do the same for
transport to the
Moon The Genius of Starship or the
genius of the principle of heavy
reusable is that the cost factors
compared to traditional Expendable
launch could potentially Reduce by two
orders of magnitude one cannot emphasize
enough what a game Cher this is Starship
is the railroad to low earth orbit and
from there we can build out to the moon
and into the solar system Starship will
be the enabler that allows us to build
hundreds of economically viable business
models in space SpaceX and blue origin
are developing Landers to carry
astronauts to the Moon surface as part
of NASA's Artemis
program this aims to put the first woman
and person of color on the lunar Surface
by
2025 but the race is not just about
human transport there's cargo and other
services too PWC estimates that the
lunar transport and Logistics Market
could be worth more than $100 billion by
2040 in
2018 when the moon became of strategic
interest to the United
States there were no lunar Landers or
lunar programs in existence in the
United States today there's over a dozen
Landers being built which is a new
market lunar transportation is going to
be the key component getting people on
and off the surface and getting
instruments and and capabilities on the
surface is going to be the immediate
need that we have over the next several
years you need to get there to have
human presence you need to build
infrastructure ahead of the human
presence being there because it's not
just about staying a couple of days and
then going it's about a permanent
infrastructure so I would put
communication and navigation ahead even
of oxygen and food because otherwise you
can't even go there going to the South
Pole is a lot different than going to
the
Equator the lighting conditions at the
South Pole are very peculiar so you have
really low incident angle light so from
a navigation perspective you can
actually get very disoriented when you
walk away from your Lander and you turn
around around and try and get back so
with that sunlight very low at you so
even small Boulders can give you Long
Shadows we need to give our crews every
bit of safety to navigate back to the
Lander our requirements of science to
accurately put our scientific
instruments and know where we put them
is important also so that navigation
piece is really important from a safety
and science perspective so
collaborations like Moonlight are very
important to us
Moonlight is the name given to the
program led by the European Space Agency
which plans to offer connectivity on the
moon it's an infrastructure project
giving exactly the same facility as
Internet and Galileo would give to human
on earth so today you imagine that the
internet goes off you don't have any
signal on your mobile phone and you
don't have any navigation signal for
your car pretty much every business Stu
where it's the same for the moon if we
want to have autonomous navigation
if we want missions on the moon to be
able to communicate back with us and
between themselves we need to have a
network of communication satellites
orbiting around the Moon allowing
communication between the Luna Mission
and the Earth and amongst each other and
including a navigation system as well
other nations are also looking into
contributing to a global program we're
starting from scratch what we were not
able to do on Earth because on Earth we
didn't start with is one system and the
will to all be interoperable so we are
capable of saying okay well we're going
to work together as the world not as a
nation to provide this service as
efficiently as possible setting up a
Communications network is also expected
to accelerate the development of
Commercial Services on the moon I can
put data relay and navigation satellites
around the moon and now I can provide
Communications for any set of users to
purchase from us as a service and so we
provide lunar distance or nears space
network communication services to the
moon and back from the Moon and even on
the back side of the moon and we can
sell that to anybody who wants a mission
to the moon or wants to put anything on
the moon so if we're building a
permanent base on the moon and we've got
the communications and navigation in
place what else do we need well we can't
do anything without power and we will
need a lot of
Power Nuclear is going to be critical if
we're really going to live there and and
work there and do science there
sustainably you need a lot more power to
execute more missions so we think that's
very important so will there not be kind
of safety and environmental
considerations doing producing nuclear
power on the moon it does sound scary to
talk about nuclear power uh in space and
on the moon uh one of the big
differences uh is one of the important
nuances is this is low-enriched uranium
it's not high enriched weapon grade
nuclear fuels so inherently it is much
safer there are also a lot of regulatory
and safety processes that we're going to
work through with governments to make
sure we can do this safely but
essentially you don't launch with a
nuclear reactor for example the nuclear
reactor is turned off when you launch
until you get to what's called a nuclear
safe orbit and what do you do with the
waste a lot of that still needs to be
developed and worked out I would say
those things are in in work can say more
on that in the future I would say how
the how the systems are going to going
to all work and play out and how all
that will be managed nuclear power on
the moon is important because of its
stability it also helps us survive the
night we have 150 hour periods sometimes
where we'll be without sunlight and we
need our systems to survive obviously
nuclear power is there all the time so
we can take advantage of that to power
our vehicles during these difficult No
Light low temperature periods the safety
concern obviously is there we would
design around it by putting the reactor
far away or building up a burm of the
lunar regolith to protect the crew
members and and distributing the power
via long cables regolith is the name for
lunar dust which actually isn't dust at
all but shards of moonrock that have
been smashed by meteorites over millions
of years it's nasty stuff which tore
into the Apollo Astronauts Moon suits
and can damage lungs we had these
white suits on when we started but the
moond dust is very very fine like powder
and so as you walk you kick it up this
dust gets all over you your suit began
to turn gray but scientists are hoping
to be able to use that regolith to
protect humans from radiation to build
habitation and more there's a name for
using the moon's resources such as
regali or ice Inu resource utilization
or
isru Lots of people talk about this as
one of the earliest potential markets
there's people that have very big
Institute resource utilization plans a
big concern for us is the plume that we
have from our rocket engine and how that
stir up the lunar
regolith
down
up and you can actually suspend that
regolith based on the the 16 gravity you
can actually suspend it just over the
surface so if we had a landing pad
constructed from regolith maybe
something that you know compacted that
regolith down into a landing pad it it
allows us to land closer to our other
systems so we don't have long traverses
for our crew members and then when you
look at living off the land from the
Institue resource utilization aspect
getting to that water ice our goal is to
get the hydrogen and oxygen out of there
to make power and obviously that ports
over into life support systems too so
for me that insitu resource U ization
takes a lot of power but those landing
pads sure would be great so if our
astronauts have access to water Air and
Power how can we mold the landscape to
help them survive we want to take the
raw material on the surface of the Moon
and make that useful so we're looking at
a number of different Technologies from
laser centering uh to
Casting when we go to the Moon we're
essentially going to be back in the
Stone Age our Architects and civil
engineers are looking back to just after
the Stone Age to what are the building
technologies that our ancestors used and
perfected and were able to make
fantastically useful structures out of
so this might be using bricks corbelling
which is a technology where you can take
these bricks and you can stack them in
certain ways that they will stand up on
their own these kinds of things are what
sort of fascinate our Architects and
civil engineers here because they're
simple they're repeatable they're
durable so we're we're attracted to that
those older technolog
as first use on the surface of the Moon
but there are some older technologies
that definitely won't be deployed on the
moon at least not to paying customers
dehydrated astronaut food from the 1960s
isn't going to keep astronauts healthy
or happy but is it possible or necessary
to grow food on the moon after 6 months
in space so more for longterm Mission
and for Mars travel the quality of the
prepackaged food degrade we are building
pods inside which we recreate climates
to grow plants and we do that on Earth
and space so a pod is a very it's kind
of a very Advanced Greenhouse you can
assemble it anywhere it's composed of a
base inside which you find all the
hardware so the atmospheric the
hydraulic system that help recreating
the climate inside and on top of the
hardware there is inflated bubble inside
which we recreate the ideal condition
for life to grow we just need like an
initial tank of water and then we can
use it for a very long time for the air
we can have compressed hair so it's not
air is not really a problem on our side
a lot of the companies that we've looked
at have amazing animated examples of
what they plan to do but the reality is
more
prosaic the first pillows that were
sending are actually not inflatable
structure there are cubic pillows inside
which we're trying to really test the
watering system because the gravity is
different on the moon we also want to
see how the solar radiation are
impacting the de vment of the plants
because this is still unknown and so the
first pillot will be very small cubes uh
step two will be to start testing
inflatable structures then step three is
going to be integrate everything and
eventually get a first biopod on the
moon mining is another industry which
many believe offers huge potential in a
future lunar economy scientists think
the moon May hold large deposits of
helium 3 which is crucial for nuclear
fusion there may be money to be made in
extracting this for use back on
Earth offworld is building swarms of
ruggedized machine intelligent robots
built on the same common platform
consisting of different species of
robots that do excavation extraction
surveying processing uh Transportation
collection and literally a myriad of
other tasks and the robots then
collaborate together working in a system
that provides an endtoend capability for
any industrial sector offworld is one of
the many lunar hopefuls trying to prove
its business model here on Earth before
setting off for the moon we have the
mining companies of our clients we're
really operating here on Earth
predominantly as the first planet with
the most value proposition and what that
means is that we can build and scale the
business here we can add value to
existing mining companies who can't mine
particular ore or mineral from places
that conventional mining cannot reach
economically and that means we can then
develop our robust systems reduce the
risks on our learning curves and develop
the intelligence and autonomy here on
Earth and then deploy to the Moon being
one of the world's first companies to
have mining development contracts on two
celestial bodies um is uh pretty
cool even if these companies are able to
do business on Earth making a success of
that same business on or around the Moon
is a giant leap not everyone believes a
self-sustaining commercial economy will
flourish on the
moon this is a study of the potential
for a lunar economy written for NASA it
found that there are more than 80
companies in 12 countries aiming to
offer services and products on or around
the Moon by 2040 but the vast majority
are counting on government contracts to
keep them going rather than households
or businesses consumers May book a stay
in a lunar Hotel buy moon rocks or other
artifacts or even choose to be buried on
the moon the report suggests but that's
about all that will be available and for
the businesso business Market other than
advertising there was nothing that could
be produced on or around the moon for
the private sector that was viable
without government support but that is
the story until 2040 lunar entreprene
are looking further out space is an
enormous human endeavor it will always
contain a government component
governments have a strategic need to be
in space International governments need
to be there but also there's room now
for the first time in history there's
room for commercial companies to be
there as the economy progresses we'll
see more activity around the Moon there
will be satellites that will be
refillable and then also Landers and
Rovers that can be refueled and the idea
of a logis IC supply chain around the
Moon where you are able to derive
resources propellants that can then be
transferred to uh customers our goal is
to be kind of the mid-stream downstream
oil and gas company in a
sense so when people say that we're
never going to get a long-term outpost
on the moon and that it will be very
similar to what happened with Apollo I
disagree because there are so many
entrepreneur and very talented engineers
and scientists working on making it
happen
there is the money there is the talent
and it's going to happen let's be honest
there's never been a lunar economy
before it's entirely possible that the
moon's commercial economy will simply be
about making life a little more
comfortable for those staying in the
bases services like streaming Netflix or
supplying coffee maybe we won't truly
know what the opportunities are until we
have people living on the lunar surface
collectively over history we' spent two
weeks of human history on the moon
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done to build the infrastructure to
build reliable
transportation not only reliable but
even uh financially reliable the road
needs to be paved before we can start
setting up shop but NASA and its
partners are not the only ones trying to
pave those roads China has its own
Ambitions to build a permanent base on
the moon and like the US space agency it
too is targeting the South Pole and
encouraging its companies to participate
in the new moon Rush are you worried
that the greater involvement of the
commercial stroke private sector in this
could accidentally lead to conflict
unmanaged conflict with a power like
China which has its own commercial and
political Ambitions for the moon I think
commercial involvement only enables
things I I don't worry about commercial
starting any type of conflict I believe
that our path back to the moon this time
under the emis program is much different
than we we did in Apollo in the sense
that we're going as an International
Coalition under a set of principles in
the emis Accords which are about safe
peaceful and prosperous um so from our
perspective those 28 countries that have
signed those aremis Accords and
committed to those principles which
includes our partners in the commercial
world that's how we'll operate and
that's how we'll live by of course China
has not and probably never will sign
those Accords
I love the competition and the race to
the moon and wanting to be first as you
can tell you know first United States
return in 50 years uh but we can do that
in a way that's uh friendly and not
adversarial I'm Not Afraid about a being
conflict in the future regarding the you
know the sharing of resources they will
realize that to have a a better
environment they need to sit together
there is a challenge for this race to
the moon or this war for the moon but
there are underlying trends that could
facilitate at least respectful and
peaceful uh if not cooperation then at
least distance that may allow us to work
around each other rather than against
each other a cold war at worst I believe
is where we're headed both Endeavors are
trying to get there they'll do their
work independently it would not really
escalate further than that we have to
hope they're right very few of those we
spoke to were prepared to acknowledge
the risk that competition for lunar
resources could spark new tension in
already strained relationships back here
on Earth but those tensions do exist
even if there is still International
collaboration on the ISS I think that
the space agencies around the world have
worked better than almost any
geopolitical group I mean it's amazing
to me now as we sit here today that we
have an International Space Station that
is still holding together an
International Coalition I think that's a
remarkable statement of what space can
actually do to bring people together and
I think that's that's going to be the
case in the future historically space
has been an area of collaboration right
where countries have come together
because it is so challenging and and
been sort of a force for Humanity and
and for good so I'd like to think that
that will continue and that we can build
on that and work together uh with other
nations we want to see more successes
for everybody participating so that we
grow this whole economy and that we have
a vibrant economy that's what it's about
whether the moon becomes Humanity's
first off-world economy will depend on
many things on Starship succeeding after
its early failures in cutting the price
of a ticket to the moon on explorers
finding and extracting valuable
resources such as water hydrogen and
helium 3 and on the world's space
fairing Nations being able to share the
moon's resources peacefully the stakes
are high right now the Moon is a
pristine Place largely undisturbed by
geopolitical or commercial rivalries
but within the next decade we expect to
see the first mining of its resources
and perhaps even the first tourists will
we trash the moon as we have trashed so
much of our home planet I don't have
that concern the Moon is a uh it's a
fragment and it's a rock and a baron
place and so I'm not necessarily worried
about contamination of the Moon itself
it lives out in space in a highly
radioactive environment we're looking at
different sites on the moon a number of
them will just be set aside
as national parks some might be strictly
for scientific purposes so that they're
not touched by any sort of commercial
activity and then probably a small
fraction would be allowed for research
and commercial use anytime you go
somewhere new it's how can we do this in
the right way maybe differently than in
the past and be mindful of those things
so that's not an area I worry
about do you think you'll ever go to the
Moon yes I
will I I want to go and and uh I'm very
uh determined when I want to do
something it might take more time than
expected but I will go I don't want to
get to a moon for a very good reason I
get motion sick in the car I think the
thing that I look up at the Moon more
than almost anything is um a certain
amount of longing I want to go back I
want us to go back I want us to go back
and I want us to explore uh I'm not sure
if I'll make it there I have a I have a
2-year-old daughter and I like to tell
her she'll have the option to go to the
Moon someday and uh and I think that
many people
[Music]
will I'm Dreaming oh that somebody
soon someone will spend a Long
Afternoon close by me making me
[Music]
soon